i'll say this simply put
there's a lot of we we address a lot of
like problems right now in in the west
in general in the united states in
particular you know we got the issue
with money right 40 40 50 of the us
currency in circulation was printed in
the past 18 months right there so we got
a financial problem now we have also a
family problem you know we have
the nuclear family has almost been
destroyed in the united states you know
we how how many kids come from you know
two-parent households with both parents
that were there by their biological
parents eighteen percent now rare yeah
eighteen percent eighteen percent yeah
some of the latest extremely rare right
which we know that nuclear families are
the backbone of a strong economy so you
have that right divorce rates are
through the roof you got masculinity in
general which is like getting thrown to
the ways that hey let's you know think
with our feelings and let's operate off
feelings and not logic and rationing you
know toxic masculinity all those other
bs and then you know you got the
polarization between the two um you know
political parties there's and then on
top of that you got the looming issues
with china and russia right you got the
russian probe which also divided the
country that was another example of a
trojan horse yeah and then you got the
looming issues with china with taiwan
and it's just there's so many problems
here that it's like just like oh man i
think the biggest one is the mass
hypnosis the kind of brainwashing that
happens to the average american out
there whether it's on social media or
through the corporate media they get a
different uh bastardized reality than of
course other people do they get put in
echo chambers they get radicalized and i
think you know the answer is not easy
but it doesn't mean we should stop doing
what we're doing i think we are having
an effect i think we should always try
to to strive to do the best we can to
help open people's visions we might not
always do it but we should also
understand we're playing for the middle
person we're not playing for for antifa
we're not playing someone who's totally
radicalized and totally insane and crazy
we're playing for the person the average
person the majority of people who are
sitting back and watching what's going
on because those people are the ones
historically that do make the big
decisions that do create the situations
that do change societies it's the people
in the middle who don't want to get
involved that actually end up doing the
most and that's why we got to play to
them that's why we got to be fair and
then i think we we shouldn't break the
rules like they break the rules bro
there's from my perspective well i
certainly think
you know all the points you brought up
are hitting the nail on the head with
the hammer i mean kids not being born
two-parent homes
the economy is based on children yes and
like lowest birth rates right now yeah
and china has is the opposite they have
a strong family unit they they you know
they they take pride in uh masculinity
you know they actually they
they don't allow porn into their country
or rock music or rap music or degenerate
type you know social media stuff so you
know they take proactive steps to
protect their side to society from
degeneracy
which side of the political conflict and
there are sides let's be real within it
there's a bunch of different factions
you know libertarians and conservatives
are very different a lot of opinions
which which side is pro family and which
side is opposed to the stan the nuclear
family
it's pretty clear it's pretty
it's very obvious it's very clear like
even me
who's who i'm i'm a childless 35 year
old i'm in a relationship but no kids
can recognize the importance of having
kids and i can understand why
conservatives looking at data are
correct then you get black lives matter
they say they want to disrupt the
nuclear family then you get the left
which is very much tearing down cultural
and you know uh cultural rules and it's
like i'll be the first to say a lot of
traditions are dumb and bad and we
should do away with them and some of
them are good and we should keep them
you know just you know burn everything
to the ground but it's very clearly left
and right and that being said to address
what you're saying luke luke there's no
middle ground
there's none look at this look at this
i'm not saying there's middle ground i'm
saying there's people in the middle who
don't want to get involved that are
watching and those are the people we
should play to i'm not saying so well
let's clarify that
almost nobody is in whatever can be
perceived to be as a middle what we have
right here is joe biden's job approval
according to civics with 141 000
responses what you're seeing is party
affiliation independent 26 approval if
we go to republican obviously it's going
to be in the gutter with two percent
approval 96 disapproval and if you go to
democrat it's 76 percent approval but
what does this show it shows that
democrats overwhelmingly still approve
of biden they're losing a lot of support
disapproval is going up but independents
lean heavily towards where republicans
are
when you look at pew's data on the
political tribes the group called the
stressed sideliners these are people who
are not political lean right politically
and the reason is we like watching
offensive comedy we like watching
comedians and making jokes we don't want
to live under a boot we like family we
like christmas we like the holidays
and we like having our money and not
have it taken by taxes i mean that's
true too you know everyone what do they
say everyone's a conservative until
they're i'm sorry everyone's liberal
until their first paycheck exactly
so my point is
there's obviously still some undecideds
the stressed sideliners or whatever but
even they lean right and so the issue is
if we are if we are a show where
we we we don't say kyle right now as a
hero we defend him acting in
self-defense and but we've not you know
like that that's a big you know
conservative right-wing trump supporter
a lot of those people outright say they
say in the chat i respect their right to
say it i understand why they say it for
me i'm like
it's a difficult situation of political
conflict and there's you know this is a
complicated situation but kyle reynolds
was certainly acting in self-defense and
in the right 100 but anyone else that
doesn't like
it's the most clear-cut self-defense
case i've ever seen in my life but so
here's my point right
if you're talking about the regular
people then i can tell you a regular
person is going to look at that and be
like
self-defense how do we know because the
jury was a group of regular people who
said not guilty across the board
but
exclusively like the entirety of the
left from leftists to the establishment
saved destiny the streamer they were all
saying it was murder they were lying
about what he did and so my point is
regular people i thought he killed black
people that's right i'm saying like it
just goes to show like the gross lack of
knowledge and awareness of people when
they look at big cases like this they
don't look at the facts they look at
what someone put on twitter or what
someone thinks feelings emotions
feelings and emotions they don't look at
the facts and that's ridiculous that's
the quote unquote left and i'm saying
the left because before reals it
includes leftists and it clues down
includes the establishment democrats but
libertarians independents moderates
republicans traditional conservatives
religious conservatives all knew the
truth
they all knew the truth now there's of
course there's always going to be people
on on the right who are believing dumb
crazy conspiracy things too
my point is
the left is clearly in some kind of
matrix
they they believe well they have their
their moral framework is is or i should
say lack thereof they have none they
don't believe in the innocent until
proven guilty they fire people from jobs
and accusations they want people
imprisoned on accusations they burn
buildings down when they don't get their
way when it comes to this kind of stuff
libertarians moderates independents
centrists right wingers conservatives
they don't do any of that stuff
so when i when we come out here and we
go on the show and we say something like
kyle written house acted in self-defense
jury said so evidence shows it seven
witnesses said it
then
we're not gonna convince anyone on the
left ever
that we are right they're just gonna say
you're racist yep so
my main point is
when it you know bringing it back to the
issue of family and everything i think
the divide is is so extreme in this
country we call it a political divide we
call polarization i think that's wrong i
think it is a grand canyon there there's
i i do not believe there's going to be a
way like even even that guy hawk newsome
the black lives matter guy in new york
who went to a trump rally and they
cheered for him and he said i want you
know to make life better and everyone's
like we do we do
then he starts expressing his opinions
on what will make life better and all of
a sudden you're like
bro if you're if you're saying you want
to burn the constitution yeah that's not
going to happen right i'm never going to
shake someone's hand in that in that
capacity yeah there i don't think
there's a way you get antifa black lives
matter and then you know even regular
americans who like christmas and family
to shake hands and agree on how to move
forward i think family could be the
solution though and you know a lot of
powerful people when they want to enact
change they if they do it intelligently
they have a process of doing it they
they do very slowly generation two two
steps forwards one step back if you look
at a lot of these kind of crazy leftist
they believe in the need not to have
children in benefit of the environment
you look a lot of them they're incapable
of reproducing because of their low
testosterone efforts they're incapable
of producing because of choices they
made with their bodies that have
negatively impacted them whether
abortions or others so so a lot of
people on the left can't and won't be
having babies a lot of people on the
right
will a lot of people who do believe in
family values will so there there might
be an aspect to this of saying if we all
have families we could teach them morals
and principles and virtues that actually
matter and transcend a lot of the
hypocrisy craziness and nonsense when it
comes to this larger depopulation agenda
that the left is predominantly affected
by and hurt by and i'll say this too the
family is is the backbone of a strong
economy you know what i'm saying you
need you need two parents you know and
there's an overwhelming amount of
evidence that shows that you know
children that come from single-parent
households have a higher likelihood of
being degenerate drug addicts criminals
etc and you need that father in place
you know to let you know that there are
consequences to your actions and punish
that bad behavior and then you need a
mother there to you know instill
nurturing values take care of you in
your childhood etc and then as you
become older and you hit adolescence
that's when your father comes in and
becomes an imperative part of your
development and we live in a society now
that says we don't need men men are
useless men are trash toxic masculinity
blah blah blah and what do we have we
have a bunch of degenerates a bunch of
spineless men you know we have
degenerate women that are running around
doing stupid things and rewards
fatherless homes exactly with financial
information so
that's obviously a big cultural
component economically though let's make
it very very simple the economy is
driven by a need to support and sustain
kids yes like a lot of money goes into
my kid needs this my kid needs that my
kid wants this my kid wants that raising
kids yes when you get older you're going
to work this is why they're saying
you're going to own nothing and you're
going to be happy because without a kid
what do you what do you need to strive
for it's the nfts yeah the forest
leather boots of agility and warcraft
were put on earth to procreate that's
why we are here we are here to have
offspring so you know a huge human part
of your fulfillment is not met if you
don't have children and you know it's
great that you know on the right they
tend to swing more towards family values
etc and that that's what's needed the
united states was built on the back of
the nuclear family you know in the in
the 20s the 50s all the economic booms
occurred from a man going to work
providing for his family you know
obviously times have changed you know
you need two parent household whatever
to make an income but the point is is
that a two pound household with a family
is the backbone of the united states how
he became an economist my humble opinion
like there's a another divide as well
between the rich and the poor there's no
more middle class it's pretty much going
away and at this point that was a
nuclear family in the middle class but
guess what taxes are going up prices are
going up inflation and there's either
rich or poor this is going to cause even
more divide because now either you have
not sort of halves yes that's my opinion
yep it's definitely uh it's definitely
huge polarization i agree i think the uh
if you look at where the left has gone
right so the left of my youth is is
mostly considered right wing now right
you know
but that's true like 10 15 years ago
like you know i mean just look at bernie
sanders yeah he's far left look look at
his opinions from 2008 you'd be like wow
that's a trump supporter yeah like
across the board you know we got to
bring our factories back and you close
the borders and it's like okay trump
yeah but you look at where the left is
today and they
they've overwhelmingly become
and it's it's almost the epitome of the
seven deadly sins you know like like
it personified like name one of the
vices and they've got it
you know i mean envy right angry they're
they're wrath filled they're prideful
they're lustful they're greedy and don't
get me wrong the right has this too
but my point is
i'm thinking about these these comments
on twitter i'm thinking about these
articles that have been written by many
left-wing activists where they're like
who cares about where this country goes
i mean that's the core message of a lot
of what they're saying who cares what
happens
who happens who cares what happens to
humanity it's blind because one thing
especially when it comes to the criminal
justice system we got crazy quotes
running around here like believe all
women
last time i checked you know men and
women fought for equality equality means
you are the same therefore you are
capable of lying just like a man and
last time i checked we live in a country
where it's
you know guilty right it's innocent
until proven guilty not guilty until
proven innocent but if you're going to
run around and say believe all women
that's ridiculous you know what i'm
saying we had brett kavanaugh a couple
years ago
testifying right and for under oath in
front of everyone on some accusations
that were not from 40 years ago that no
one had proof of and no he did this to
me and her friends even denied it that
her friends denied it no witnesses no
nothing but we got a guy that's going to
be a supreme court justice
basically in a cloud world a clown
circus where he has to testify for his
own innocence why because he's going to
be a supreme court justice i get it he
needs to be held to the highest standard
of law but at the same time it's like yo
come with some facts before you're going
to go ahead and make a crazy accusation
i'll se i'll i'll put it this way you
know a lot of this is one example a lot
of people like to say you know it's
unfair you're taking the worst examples
of the left and the left does it to the
right and i'm like okay well hold on a
second
when we talk about like eric swalwell
right he tweeted we should ban people
from flying i'm not gonna pretend that
every democrat wants that you know but
probably a lot of them don't agree with
that i'm not gonna pretend that every
everyone on the left
is or and they're liberal gun owners
they exist too yeah but i will tell you
that what is true
overwhelmingly not absolutely is that
they believe in a fictitious reality
and then they believe in that fictitious
reality that everyone on the right are
truly the ones who live in the
fictitious reality but the truth is
russiagate was a lie jesse smallett was
a lie the covington kids was a lie the
cow written how story was a lie
every day they are putting out lies
and i think what actually divides us is
are you in the matrix or are you outside
of it the rant house case was was
terrible like
it is so if you watch that trial
it's clear-cut you know what i'm saying
like they they they were trying to like
mess this kid up man and everyone's
running around oh no well he killed
black people no he didn't people
caucasian ate it up you know what i'm
saying but it's like they're just trying
to do and say anything to to get a
reaction they don't even look at the
facts they go off what their friend says
on twitter what possible allegations are
and this it's crazy because it's
this country was
founded upon do
process man and you literally have a guy
that got acquitted
with beyond like
clearest cut case of self-defense i've
ever seen if that was tough
i am scared of the future to get a guy
like that that was clearly innocent you
look you look at what happens when we
bring on you know someone like this and
they say you defend you you here's the
fascinating thing and i i'll just i'll
just say it outright with ra the rugged
man when he came on
and again you know look as far as
anything goes with the shenanigans and
the yelling at each other like me
yelling and hemming them like i'm over
that but what i do think is important is
you know here's a guy
who told us we were supporting the cops
we were bootlicking over the ahmed
arboree case in the derrick chauvin case
when he was literally defending the
state in its in its entirety our issue
was what we said is
these specific individuals have rights
that are in question and he was like if
you defend a single police officer
you're a bootlicker and it's like but
you're supporting literal state
prosecution in the prison system which
i'm not a fan of i'm not a fan of any of
that
i'm a fan of individual rights but some
so that you know ultimately i'm not
trying to drag him specifically but it
was it's a fresh conversation and it's a
good example these are people who are
like you're the bootlicker i'm in favor
of state prosecution and i'm like why
are you cheering for the prosecutors why
are you literally cheering for more
people to go into the car and to be
incarcerated i thought the left were the
ones that said the system is broken it
needs to be abolished but then as soon
as they have power on their side they
just use it to its fullest extent and
say don't question me
yeah my thing is
you gotta you gotta be on no one's side
you gotta look at it like okay what are
the facts and what does the law say
simple as that man you'll you'll find
you're going to be you're going to be in
the cultural right if that's the case
yeah exactly because like i said
russian
ukraine
covington kids trump throwing fish into
the koei pond all of these stories every
day just lie after lie after a lie over
and over and over again and certain a
certain point it's like if you are like
i'm not going to be on anyone's side i'm
going to look objective objectively at
the facts you know what's going to
happen jack posoba is going to be like
you're correct sir i disagree with you
but you're right and someone on the left
is going to be like you're a conspiracy
theorist of course and you're going to
be like but i just read i just read this
this report from new york times new york
times reported ukrainian court said that
ukrainians were interfering in the u.s
election the new york times published
that nope sorry that's a conspiracy
theory if you're if you're on the left
because you got to be in the matrix you
got to follow the narrative i was just
going to say you you started to sound
like a white supremacist there for a
little bit
i got my hood in the back somewhere
i'm going to put it on after the show
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time